so now about the Hollywood wonder women  who made their way to the desert for the  Palm Springs International Film Festival  and that is where they were met by your  own Wonder Woman Mary Hart become Palm  Springs best film fit can you go back  I'm sorry I'm so nervous  say it again Palm Springs Film Festival  Palm Springs Film Festival when they  think about it too much that's when it  gets great gal was still charmingly  nervous in our exclusive backstage  interview this year's Rising Star Award  recipient was armed with her Wonder  Woman director patty Jenkins and they  gave Mary a huge hint as to what to  expect in their upcoming sequel I know  there were a lot of questions about will  Lynda Carter the original Wonder Woman  on television will she make a cameo in  this one we'll see we actually  desperately tried to get her in the  first one and we won't say anything yet  but we certainly there's no no lack of  trying  I need breaking news come on